[Music]
my grandmother if she knew now what i
was making would be very surprised
mochi is originally from japan it's a
white pastry that's made from rice flour
it's stuffed with asuki beans that's the
traditional mochi
our mochi has become hawaiian mochi my
own style
[Music]
we live in hawaii and if you look around
we have deserts and snow we have
tropical rainforest and all the flowers
the birds and the oceans it's all very
colorful
[Music]
this is hilo town i would consider it to
be old hawaii everything is a little bit
slower
hilo is where i grew up and where my
grandparents settled when they first
came from japan
[Music]
they came as workers for the plantation
and the cane fields they were seeking a
better life and so did the other groups
of people that came from all over the
world filipinos chinese koreans they all
had to live together and they all shared
their food
the japanese contribution was the mochi
every time i taste it i think back to
where i came from when i think of my
grandma
she as a treat would make her mochi
her mochi was the reason that i had
interest to keep mochi on the menu of
hawaii
two ladies kitchen is called two ladies
because we started with just my aunt and
myself i knew that my aunt knew how to
make mochi but there was nobody else to
pass it on to and i knew that mochi is
my calling
when i first started the business it was
just my family who helped me
my parents are now in their 90s and they
still come to the mochi shop
a lot of our flavors are found in hawaii
we have a strawberry mochi with a fresh
strawberry on top of the beans and it's
wrapped in the white mochi that is very
popular lilikoi is passion fruit so i
use the fresh nectar and we make mochi
we use the fruits of the season
persimmons peaches and nectarines
pineapple on and on now i have a ginger
mochi brownie mochi a marshmallow like a
rocky road i never say no to someone's
suggestion
it's been almost 25 years and now we
have lines out the door
it's not only the japanese people who
embrace mochi but it's become a hawaiian
food
i meet people from all over the world
and they too now love mochi it sticks
everyone together other races culture
our family friends
mochi just makes you feel happy and
that's why i say mochi is love
you